anyway you've been doing the show for
seven years now it's the longest running
original netflix show ever that's
amazing
so
y'all i know that y'all had to meet like
way before so when did y'all first meet
well uh i was developing a movie called
nine to five it was not casual yet
never heard of him with your friend
but now she none of that existed lily
tomlin dolly part and i wasn't a
television person and i was developing
it as a dark comedy and um
i heard lily tomlin is downtown l.a
doing a one-woman show called appearing
nightly and i went by myself
and i was
i was just knocked off my feet i was
totally smitten by her and i first met
her going backstage and i said to myself
i'm not making a movie about secretaries
unless she's in it
so i thought well we're going to have to
change it
and i was like we're taking shorthand
and
i had a chat that's how you got the job
so do you remember that the first time
that y'all met yes i was i was totally
knocked over because i was such a fan of
fondest and
and i had a clue hairdo and everything
so when she came backstage it was really
exciting for me i think she was sort of
trepidatious but i was like
could i can i get like an autograph can
i get like um
can you get a note to my mother
[Laughter]
asking for all the things it's amazing
it what's been cool like working with
dolly like were you kind of nervous
because she'd never done like a big
thing before
uh
were you nervous no working i was
nervous but not because of her i was
this one i was nervous because of her oh
my god oh i love that when you're so
inspired by someone and you're well and
that's cool yeah yeah she wasn't sure i
was going to behave or
that's like working with blake shelton
that's like that's what my life is like
on the voice oh yeah so i'm like what's
he gonna say um so wait is it true that
dolly might actually appear on grayson
frankie i heard that this is true
okay
okay i'm very excited
we're very so that was like the greatest
and she's on our last episode we were
just
so excited that the show was going to
end with the three of us i know that's
what i'm saying like because we really
haven't seen that since so that's
amazing like kind of and also her
documentary is coming out yeah and nine
to five the anniversary of it so it's
like a lot of things kind of coming
together at once
and and
the way she is in the last episode is
just perfect i mean you couldn't think
of a better way oh what a half dolly up
here i know it's a tv that was a great
tease oh it was so good yeah i'm a
little upset about it i'm like wait
watch
[Music]
you